je vous parle souvent ici de michaël
blanc qui est condamné à perpétuité à la
prison à ben ali pour détention de
cabanis et vous êtes nombreux à les
visiter son site pour pour l'aider ce
soir voici
voici le père de michaël blanc
jean claude blanc bonsoir soit bien
heureux de vous voir on est moins de
voir votre fils mais on espère que ça
viendra bientôt en tous les cas
quelles sont les dernières nouvelles de
michael c'est toujours statu quo statu
quo la situation en judiciaire actuelle
c'est le recours en cassation
voilà c'est tout est prévu pour quand
date butoir ce serait le 1er mai le 1er
mai hélène votre femme est là bas oui et
vous ici vous coordonnez le comité le
comité de soutien on va parler de tout
ça interview vérité en ébauche parlant
le génial
bien vous vous êtes artisan en
haute-savoie votre épouse était employée
comptable vous êtes vous n'êtes pas les
moyens financiers inépuisable donc c'est
vrai que ça va être très compliqué pour
vous en ce moment d'organiser la défense
et la sortie de votre fils alors lui il
avait un mickaël un cap2 cuisinier puis
il a travaillé dans divers restaurants
en suisse en belgique et en 95 il est
besoin d'évasion
il est parti en malaisie est-ce qu'à
l'époque vous aviez eu peur de ça quand
il est parti qui vous a dit je pars en
asie quand même la ssii s'est pas
spécialement où il est parti tout
d'abord en inde et après en malaisie
donc elle a travaillé un moment malaisie
puis à manille alors bannie faut dire
aujourd'hui ce que c'est devenu parce
que c'est vrai qu'on a une image de ben
ali
aujourd'hui c'est devenu une espèce de
saint tropez ben ali un ccc la jet set
mick jagger belmondo marc lavoine
jean luc delarue ophélie winter alors
ceux des hôtels de luxe des bungalows
beaucoup de calmes et pas seulement du
cabanis donc faut savoir ce que c'est
devenu aujourd'hui bien lui il arrive
là-bas michael ils travaillent sur des
chantiers de bateaux de plaisance et
puis monter un magasin de vêtements vous
aviez des nouvelles régulièrement de lui
oui pas spécialement mais bon
une fois par mois oui une fois par mois
et puis fait des voyages pour
approvisionner son magasin de vêtements
et un jouet part en inde alors là les
versions divergent un peu parce que il
ya le fait qu'il soit parti en âne pour
acheter des vêtements pour
approvisionner son magasin et puis à une
autre version qui dit qu'il est parti
faire de la moto on à la vraie version
c'est quoi enfin d'après vous ben en
fait il est je pense qu'il était parti
chercher les vêtements et puis comme
comme ça se passe dans ces pays là on
doit sortir du pays pour le visa pour
rire les visas donc est parti en inde et
en a profité pour faire un tour dans le
sud de l'inde
voila voila et en obtenant donc il a
pris uniquement de plongée complet qu'un
ami lui a remis ce dénommé philippe donc
les franco-israéliens qui lui dit est ce
que tu peux emporter ses bouteilles de
plongée à ma vie est ce que c'était
vraiment un ami ou est-ce que c'était
une rencontre de voyage c'est une
connaissance je pense comme ça se passe
dans tous ces pays là on rencontre
quelqu'un qu'on connaît par son prénom
ne comprenais pas vraiment mais ça
devient vite un ami donc il a il lui a
fait confiance
et voilà ils leur amener son matériel et
donc le matériel était complet et dont
deux bouteilles de plongée qui
renfermait soi-disant de la drogue voilà
donc il y avait à l'intérieur la douane
a passé les bouteilles de plongée aux
rayons x ils ont trouvé 189 boulettes et
178 petits paquets de haschich donc au
total ça fait 3 kg 8
alors effectivement bon la question se
pose ça change rien à la situation
est ce qu'il a été piégé par un escroc
ou est-ce que lui il a vu là dedans un
trafic juteux pour se faire un peu
d'argent je dire c'est pas non plus
extrêmement guy minel pour nous michael
est innocent en fait il s'est fait
piéger mais il faudrait savoir à qui
profite le crime
voilà donc les il lui dit qu'il n'a pas
assisté à la foule c'est à dire que lui
dit déjà toute façon moi on me dit qu'il
y avait du haschich dans les bouteilles
moi j'ai pas assisté au moment où on a
sorti le haschich des bouteilles donc
déjà l'huile des pâtes et moins de ce
dont on l'accuse en tous les cas en fait
il n'était pas encore passé à la douane
il avait deux sacs un été complètement
détruit l'autre contenait le matériel
avait une croix dessus
dès qu'il a saisi lé sac de douaniers
lorrains l'ont rattrapé et il n'avait
encore pas passer la douane on a à dire
quelque chose dans les bouteilles et ça
a duré plusieurs heures
il avoue le débit céline bouteille on va
dit non non ils ont embarqué les
bouteilles parce qu'en regardant à
travers les bouteilles on peut voir
quand même
ouais par le trou de vent mais dont ils
ont percé et 6 et après alors ce
philippe qui lui avait confié ses
bouteilles
il n'a jamais été recherchées finalement
on sait pas où il est je peux l'idée
excusez moi mais l'idée d'engager un
détective privé pour le retrouver
oui j'avais pensé je pense que ça serait
facile de le retrouver mais ça ne les
intéresse pas du tout faits intéresse
pas les valides les indonésiens rue le
28 décembre 1999 femme hélène reçoit un
fax du consul de france 2 à denpasar
banque est la capitale de ba vi et
laisse passer les fêtes avant de vous
prévenir que je propose est séparé non
et du tellement choqué c'est ça je ne
sais pas quoi vous dire je suis un fax
oui ça doit être le 28 elle avait eu le
coup de téléphone avant elle a proposé
une audi hors lui se retrouve en garde à
vue michael donc à bali 27 par cellule
sans eau ni toilettes
des fois on amène des gens qui ont été
blessés par balles enfin bon c'est ces
pays là s'est il est là au milieu du
sang il n'a pas le droit de faire de
promenade il ya un premier procès où là
les avocats votre famille assister au
procès me alors quand elle arrive là bas
elle voit le prétoire pour la salle du
tribunal les avocats commis d'office qui
sont assoupis le juge qui dort et le
procureur qui réclament le swing de
maurs et ses 4,4 des fils des bus n'a
pas eu de traducteurs en fait il ya eu
aussi un traducteur commis d'office mais
qui me parlent l1 perdu ma part la
confiance et donc le souhait thaïlande
oui parce que là-bas ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que le cannabis est un
signe le haschich et assimilés à une
drogue dure
dire que pour eux c'est comme trafic
d'héroïne ou trafic de cocaïne donc un
soutien des autorités françaises
justement c'est que les les autorités
françaises il ya un consul de france
dabach peut le dire qu'ils se bougent
pas tellement ou quoi
les inconduites maintenant voilà oui
c'est ça c'est un consul honoraire c'est
à dire qu'il est fier d'autres choses
imaginons fait pas que ça contre les
consuls honoraires vad aux activités oui
alors le procureur réclame la peine de
mort aux propos pour ce à quoi donc et
le verdict en fait et transformé par le
juge ce devient un cap et 8 et enfin en
paix tu étais quand même c'est beaucoup
et même les ballerines et sont surpris
quand même les gens là-bas et dit c'est
quand même bizarre parce qu' il dise
l'indonésie veut faire un exemple ça
sûrement là c'est pour ça je vous dis à
qui profite le crime
ils veulent montrer veulent s'en servir
voilà les américains leur disent lutter
contre la drogue
donc ils disent voilà on va montrer
qu'on lui tend temps en temps ils en
prennent un comme ça et puis le le
condamne à mort et quand c'est pas mars
à perpétuité ces histoires de midnight
express son histoire et du caire à paris
le ministère des affaires étrangères
fait pas grand chose ils ne bougent pas
tellement et alors quand on voit ce qui
se passe là bas par exemple un colonel
indonésien pour comparer un qui a
décapité deux commerçants chinois qu'il
avait volée il prend trois ans un
balinais qui avait violé et tué une
fillette
il prend quatre ans donc tu vois la
différence et lui pour 3 kg 8 de deux
chiffres il prend un père m dernièrement
une personne s'était arrêtée avec 165 kg
de haschisch
ouais il est quinze ans ouais c'est ça
mais c'est sa soixante
peut-être capsule d'ecstasy ces quatre
ans ouais tu es une personne c'est un
art in voilà bah oui ce qu'il faudrait
leur dire ce soir là la france pour le
moment
enfin je sais pas vous allez nous le
dira mais neuf le gouvernement français
enfin l'état français a fait quoi
c'est à dire que pendant qu'il ya le
procès c'est une ingérence ouais donc
ils ne peuvent pas être trop agir mais
pour y suivre quand même la sphère web
on leur demande en tous les cas on ne
lâchera pas je voulais donc vous
remplissez pas les moyens de payer la
rançon en dessous des fois ça peut
s'arranger
par exemple si donné un million de
francs on est à peu près sûr que si vous
donniez un million de francs b avec 10
ans quand même
enfin ça reste à la fraîcheur et l'ont
enfin disons que ça serait une façon de
le faire est de le faire sortir
généralement les gens qui se font choper
là bas c'est arrivé à des types du
sentier qui sont fait arrêter l'année
dernière là bas ils ont donné 150 mille
balles trois cent mille balles ils sont
repartis tout de suite voilà et vous le
million vous n'avez pas toutes façons
donc voilà alors lieu un deuxième procès
encore pire que le premier parce que le
premier déjà c'était pas terrible avec
le juge qui dormait le deuxième procès
c'est l'appel donc c'est passé à huis
clos
là ils ont appris que le procès avait eu
lieu hier que l'astuce est pire que tout
ce que tout le monde a appris que la
posture et avait eu lieu à huis clos et
que la peine de perpétuité avait été
confirmée c'est ça c'est ça alors il
reste la cassation passé en train de se
préparer un petit peu peur que ça se
passe comme la peine vous avertissent
pas non en fait le procureur demande
toujours la peine de mort toujours la
peine de mort c'est pas possible
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire pour vous
aider
non mais on est tout à fait prêt à vous
aider vite nous parce que si une rançon
d'un million francs la rigueur si
l'argent pourrait le libérer mais si
c'est l'argentin millions de francs dans
dix ans
nous avait demandé on a entendu parler
d'un million 4 pour descendre de la
peine de mort à la prison à vie
donc on a refusé de passer de faire ça
et puis c'est déjà descendu mais si on
leur propose de l'argent ils vont dire
gros ils en on va descendre un petit peu
alors commencez pas donc à part la
pression médiatique que les médias
peuvent faire sur le gouvernement
c'est le plus important gouvernement
français s est pas prêt ce problème
c'est qu'il ya des gens
excusez moi mais c'est déjà un peu
susceptible donc si on n'intervient ils
vont dire c'est l'impérialisme non plus
américain ce coup ci mais français il
intervient dans nos affaires on est un
pays
voilà on est un pays souverain à
l'indonésie donc les français viennent
nous expliquer comment il faut juger des
gens ils ont qu'à s'occuper des
problèmes qu'elle chez eux et c'est ne
faut pas non plus les énerver c'est ça
qui est compliqué c'est à dire que il
faut clairement pas de pression sans
pour autant les les énerver on sait
comment leur faire plaisir pour qu'ils
le lâchent
oui parce que même la psy c'est l'argent
encore georges fleury demanderont
toujours plus dense et qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire
j'emploie c'est très difficile je pense
que
y a que la politique puisse faire
quelque chose on s'aperçoit que il est
vraiment otages et on sait pas qui est
ce que ça peut arranger le cas le
week-end et c'est vrai quand on a un peu
sceptique je peux faire déjà scellé
chauve site internet pour se renseigner
le plus de beaucoup de gens y vont je
pense que là on est prêt renseignez de
ce site internet elle s'écrit sur
l'écran pendant que je le dis d'accord
c'est magique c'est vous ne ferez deux
cent mille connexions
ça représente un peu près 1700
connexions par jour depuis deux mois
problème c'est que au niveau politique
ils ont des ennuis aussi drake les
hausses pas trop bouger on sent que
suivant les parties à le servir de
week-end vous êtes un argent 1 voilà on
va s'organiser je crois qu'il ya un ccp
il ya quelque chose on peut
oui un compte bancaire qui est ouvert au
nom de week-end donc qui est sur le net
ou si on vient te voir tous sa gamme
voilà c'est comme ça qu'on peut l'aider
déjà 100 de l'argent bloqué des bons
avocats des bons interprètes et puis
peut-être pour payer une rançon
merci monsieur blanc c'est beaucoup